[Music]
we met ariana grande as a Nickelodeon
actress watching but I gotta tell ya I
always knew she'd be a superstar singer
I'm releasing my new single in two days
it's called the way and the features Mac
Miller and I'm super excited
[Music]
I was on you know a kids television show
I that my fans would love it but I
didn't know that the real world would
take me seriously as long as re proved
herself and a year later she did it
again
more horns bigger vocals less problems
problem was the first of many hits off
re sophomore album my everything I'm
exhausted but I'm very happy she teamed
up with the weekend
[Music]
and said
[Applause]
[Music]
2016 the year things got well dangerous
I feel like I gave birth in a way you
know to a child but it's a musical child
[Music]
do whatever you want whatever you want
whatever feels natural for yourself
ari got straight-up sexy
and her lyrics cheeky AAS luck is that
the sign before we get to re latest
sweetener seems only fair to also honor
her epic work as an actress see ladies
in my own chemical on content re skills
getting killed
on screen are top-notch I like taking a
vacation from being myself it's really
fun to like be a character for a minute
and just like be silly and many people
left
she's also the queen of versatility she
does murder and musicals it's the most
fun I've ever had in my whole life one
of my favorite shows since it opened on
Broadway I'm having the time of my life
and we can't forget re the master
impersonator
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
here we are
August 17 has finally arrived the day
we've been blessed with sweetener our
eSports studio album why is it called
sweetener um because it's kind of about
like bringing light to a situation or to
someone's life or somebody also brings
light to your life or sweetening the
situation I worked with um Pharrell and
[Applause]
and it was a really awesome experience
done
[Music]